Let us recall what Napoleon was doing,
before entering into the Third Coalition war,
with which Napoleon is truly established
as a dominant figure in Europe.
So - in 1799. he takes power.
At first with two more consuls,
but then self-proclaimed for First Consul.
And so he takes power.
He gets first - I will write it in capital letters -
First Consul.
Then in 1802, but before we reached 1802,
let me tell you what he did in 1800.
In 1800, when he took power,
the Second Coalition's war is still under way.
We have discussed this briefly. Napoleon, or rather
France, losing positions, losing a lot
of what has already been won at the First Coalition with Italy.
The Austrians return it.
That is why Napoleon decides to borrow and cross the Alps.
Here's his picture.
This is Napoleon, who crosses the Alps.
It crosses the Alps.
He leads troops through the Alps to return
what he thought he had to regain from Austria.
And in the last video tutorial we learned
how did the First Coalition finish?
So in 1800. he returns or goes back to Italy.
He pulls out to bring Italy back.
When we talk about Italy,
it's about the kingdom of Italy,
which was northern Italy.
We are not talking about the Neapolitan Kingdom,
which was in the south of Ethiopia. Nor for the papal states.
Actually let me show you this.
If we get down here.
You will see that when people speak of the Kingdom of Italy
at that time, they actually talk
for this region here above, which is in northern Italy.
And Papal states are here.
And the Neapolitan Kingdom is down here.
Compared to modern Europe, the two countries,
which we associate with today's Europe and which
did not exist in a unified form at the beginning of the 19th century.
are Italy and Germany.
They were fragmented
of many kingdoms.
And as I have already mentioned, Germany from that time,
this confederation of kingdoms
was called the Holy Roman Empire,
in which the Austrian king was called ... he wore the title
Emperor of the Holy Roman Empire.
But he is not actually a horse ...
has not controlled the Holy Roman Empire
in a centralized manner.
It is actually controlled by several smaller kingdoms.
Anyway, let's go back to Napoleon.
Here he crossed the Alps in 1800.
This ends when he returns the captured.
He defeated Austria.
And this is basically the end of the Second Coalition.
That's what we learned in the latest video tutorial.
In 1801. we have the contract from Lunaville.
End of the Second Coalition.
There is no contract with Britain until next year
just because of exhaustion.
But that is irrelevant - it was a very short-term contract.
And then, in 1802,
before we start talking about the Third Coalition,
Napoleon is pushing the Constitution to the tenth year.
Why do we say the tenth year?
You remember that they had written a new, revolutionary calendar.
That's why - because of the revolutionary calendar
this was the tenth year of the revolution.
But most important from Napoleon's point of view
is the first. He says:
"The French people point out, and the Senate proclaims
Napoleon Bonaparte for First Consul to Life.
First Consul to Life.
If you think, you will understand that
Napoleon is given a status similar to King,
in view of the fact that ...
black white is recorded,
that he will rule France for the rest of his life.
Then we reach 1803.
But before 1803,
remember what's happening at the same time here.
We have the revolution in Haiti,
the Haitian revolution,
which - if you remember the video lessons,
Haiti was
the most profitable enslaved colony in the world.
As the slaves rebelled and received their freedom,
it was no longer so profitable for France,
as it was before.
And do not forget that the whole French Revolution begins,
because France is free of steam.
That's why Napoleon is trying to regain slavery.
Which generally returns to him.
Desalin and the other revolutionaries
learn about it and start it
to oppose Lukler even more.
Leclerk and the French occupiers
are ruined by yellow fever,
and Desalin is a very aggressive general.
That's why he's starting to lose Haiti.
We also have Rochambo,
if you remember it from those video tutorials - he's an extremely brutal figure
and takes on Leclerk.
So we have a revolution in Haiti.
And in a sense it can be said,
that they are starting to lose Haiti.
They lose Haiti.
And at the same time - the year 1802,
with the entrance in 1803.
Napoleon begins to realize,
that Britain controls the seas.
Britain has a dominant military fleet.
And as they begin to lose Haiti,
your primary source of income,
but Britain dominates,
Napoleon generally renounces North America.
So Napoleon gives up North America.
Outside of Haiti,
which is the main source of income for the French Empire,
also had the territory of Louisiana,
which is generally the average 1/3
from what we call the United States today.
And Napoleon decides -
Britain has a dominant fleet,
I give up Haiti,
anyway, Desalin would probably take it away,
why not give up straight across the continent.
If I do not sell Louisiana or Britain,
or the US will probably be in a good position
to take it away from me.
So he decides to sell Louisiana.
For me as an American
and an American born in Louisiana,
the chain of events that led to this,
is absolutely amazing.
Because when you know about it
from the point of view of America,
you're just saying - Hey God, Thomas Jefferson
has bought Louisiana for $ 15 million.
Why someone will suddenly come to him
to sell this vast territory?
And the reason is that Napoleon has realized,
that he or she will probably lose it anyway.
Britain has an unbeatable fleet.
And at the same time he had nothing,
to protect them in these areas.
Another valuable asset was Haiti.
The combination of Britain and its fleet
and the Haitian slaves' uprising have led to this
The United States to succeed
what is today the average 1/3 of the continent.
You probably think, "Well, if they had never done it,
if they ever managed to ever conquer
the entire west coast? "
It is these little things in history,
although not necessarily small,
but they lead you to
huge changes in our modern world.
But it is enough for that.
And so he sells Louisiana.
Britain dominates with its fleet.
At first Napoleon thinks
to build troops here
and attack the United Kingdom.
But he realizes,
that Britain's fleet is unbeatable.
And I think
Britain begins to feel a little confident,
and she does not like what benefits Napoleon has
in the last two wars.
And so Britain declared war in 1803.
in May 1803.
Great Britain or otherwise
The United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland,
the same thing is.
The United Kingdom declares war.
You can accept this
such as the beginning of the Third Coalition war.
But it is not yet a coalition.
Only the United Kingdom is. only UK.
And it really became hot in 1805.
In 1805. everyone else jumps.
Now we are talking about a real coalition.
Austria and Russia join the UK.
And as you know Austria all the time,
in each of these coalitions,
lost territories at the expense of France and, above all, of Napoleon.
They just seek revenge.
Britain in a sense feels this -
they control the waters, they also seek revenge.
And Russia does not like this champion Napoleon.
And so they all get involved.
There are two interesting corners
of the Third Coalition war.
Let me write it down.
This is the Third Coalition.
It includes other,
but these are the great powers.
This is the Third Coalition.
And the first thing that happens,
or actually two things that happen at the same time -
in October 1805. the French navy is destroyed
from the British at the Battle of Trafalgar.
This is Trafalgar here - here it is written.
Trafalgar.
Destroyed by Napoleon's good old friend
Admiral Horatio Nelson.
This type was definitely a thorn in Napoleon's eyes.
Horatio Nelson
He defeats the ships of Napoleon in the battle of the Nile,
after which the troops were scattered in Egypt.
And now he comes and generally destroys
the French Navy in the Battle of Trafalgar.
Here's a picture of the battle.
The only reassurance for Napoleon
from this battle it was,
that to the end
Horatio Nelson is hit by a bullet
and he died at Trafalgar.
And it really cemented the royal fleet,
the UK fleet, which is already dominant
and defeats the French fleet,
which was the only fleet,
with which it could have measured its strength in some way.
The defeat at Trafalgar
really cemented British domination over the seas.
This is actually a picture of the Battle of Trafalgar.
This is the battle here.
A group of ships that shoot each other,
you can not really understand what's going on.
And just to make the connection with modern Britain,
and more precisely with today's London,
this is a picture of Trafalgar Square here.
He was baptized at the Battle of Trafalgar,
with which Britain has established itself as a dominant maritime force.
This is Trafalgar Square in London.
Trafalgar Square.
If you go to this square, you will see the Nelson column.
Here's the Nelson column,
named after Horacezo Nelson, Nelson's column.
And at the top there is a small figure,
and maybe it's actually quite big,
but small on the background of the column,
the figure belongs to Horatio Nelson himself.
This was a little deviation,
this has happened during the war with the Third Coalition.
So Napoleon's fleet is destroyed.
But he does not give up.
He just says, "Well, no problem,
with you I can do nothing more,
but look in Europe - I can make big stunts there. "
So he takes his troops ...
He has already refused to attack Britain by sea.
He realizes that it is not realistic to do so.
Let me show you how the troops moved
at that time.
He had troops here
and has refused to attack the United Kingdom.
And what he does - goes to the Austrians.
And the Austrians are gathering troops here.
They actually thought there was a chance
the military campaign to be brought mostly to Italy.
And so they concentrated their troops there,
which will be a major mistake.